[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
this is Sky News live from the cenotaph
in central London as the nation prepares
to fall silent to remember its War dead
hello a very good morning King Charles
will lead the Remembrance Day
commemorations for the first time as
Monarch We'll Be Live across the UK as a
two-minute silence is observed at 11
o'clock with reeds laid here at the
cenotaph by members of the royal family
senior politicians and Faith leaders
it'll be a poignant moment for the royal
family remember it Sunday was considered
by Queen Elizabeth II as one of the most
significant and important engagements in
the Royal calendar
our Royal correspondent
Rhiannon Mills reports
50 years ago he placed his first wreath
through the decades always one step
behind his mother this year he'll step
up as Monarch and head of the Armed
Forces
program Alistair Graham supported him as
his Equity between 2002 and 2004 with
Britain caught up in the Gulf War the
now King's dedication to the military
was clear we were tasked to rearrange
the program to make sure that his
majesty could give as much time as
possible to the regiments uh families
that were left behind while they were
serving the next realm of regiments
going out to replace those that have
been part of initial Invasion and
maintaining very close links through the
Chiefs of Staff to understand what was
going on and how the how the war was
progress and I think it's it's an
intrinsic part of his role as king and
he understands that there is an
indelible link to our Armed Forces
those who know him well say his
understanding developed Early Learning
to Fly With The Ref training with the
parachute regiment and serving as a
captain in the Navy making him some
would say the most military trained King
we've ever had
since 2017 another Duty has been placed
on him laying the Queen's wreath as she
watched on
it was deeply symbolic that the queen
during her lifetime was able to hand
over that important responsibility to
her son and while yes this weekend will
be the first time that he places that
wreath as Monarch the familiarity of
that site means it won't entirely be a
distraction from those they're here to
remember
nearly 10 000 people will join the Royal
British Legion March past 400 veterans
from the Falklands War forming the
largest contingent 40 years since the
war among them Andrew Lawless who says
the king's presence will be welcomed
as he said himself he wants to follow
his mother's footsteps so his his sense
of Duty his sense of service is is
definitely there we know that there's a
solemn part too as well you know it's
not like when I'm marching past The
Descent attack will be you know the
names will be going by through my head
off the of friends and colleagues that
are not here this weekend the queen has
still been a focus at events like the
Festival of remembrance her son the king
now leading the family and the nation as
we all pay tribute to others who've
served Rihanna Mills Sky News in central
London
well our Royal correspondent Laura
bundock is here with me and Remembrance
Sunday is such an important day for the
nation to come together and remember
those who've lost their lives in
Conflict but today of course has this
added poignancy doesn't it for the royal
family given that King Charles will be
here laying a wreath for the first time
as Monarch just months after his mother
died yeah it feels very significant
doesn't it because this is today another
Milestone along that transition to a new
monarch and another one of those moments
another one of those days where I think
we will all be remembering just how
things have changed how things are
different now of course the king knows
the routine here he was laying the
wreath on behalf of his mother since
2017 but it is his first time doing it
as Monarch and I'm sure he'll be well
aware of that the poignancy of that
moment will not be lost on him he does
though totally understand the connection
and the Deep connection between the
armed forces the significance of today
and the link with the royal family as
well not just because this father served
in the Navy his grandfather as well but
I think he and himself has been very
keen to learn about what it is to be a
service Personnel what it is to go on
operations he's always had an interest
in that and the training side of things
and the technology side of things and
the impact it has on families as well
and of course he's met veterans
throughout the years but I feel today
perhaps it's also marking a bit of an
end of That World War II generation in a
way with the passing of the queen
although having said that I've just met
someone who's 100 years old who's served
in World War II so he will be here today
very much part of the March but I think
the king appreciates how the Armed
Forces work he gets it he's served in
uniform he he himself he knows what it
takes for the families for the men and
women themselves as well and he
understands the Deep importance of today
to his mother and to the nation as he
now lays that wreath on behalf of the
nation so real significance for the
queen as we know I think she only missed
seven of these events at the cenotaph
over her long rain which is quite
extraordinary in itself isn't it yeah
but today he will lay his own wreath and
it's going to be different it's a new
wreath now to use Monarch isn't it yes
it is so here's wreath will be based on
the wreath of his mother and his
grandfather so you'll see the black
leaves forming the base of it there'll
be fewer poppies we're told larger
poppies but in a nod to the queen he
will have the ribbon in the color of the
Royal racing color so Scarlet purple and
gold which is a tradition the queen was
obviously Keen to incorporate into her
wreath a wreath too today for Camilla as
Queen consort and of course we'll see
Prince William now Prince of Wales
laying the wreath that his father would
have laid he'll be laying that on behalf
of himself and the Princess of Wales too
so you you'll get a real sense I think
of the transition of power I mean just
look at the lineup of prime ministers
we'll see as well but it's apparent
everywhere and I think today more than
any day when we see the king be very
interesting I think I think we'll see
emotion on his face especially in that
two-minute silence perhaps
as he takes on this Duty I mean the
queen in some ways it was a significant
and symbolic gesture when she asked him
to lay the wreath on her behalf about
five years ago and I think some saw that
as this transition handing over some of
the roles and responsibilities to get
people used to this idea so it's not
like we haven't seen him doing this
there is just this added symbolism this
added importance today because he is now
King and and we should reflect on the
atmosphere here Laura because people
have been able to gather members of the
public since about eight o'clock when
they opened up the street a lot of
security around ahead of that of course
and there is a there's a sort of somber
atmosphere but there's also a sense of
old friends coming together as well
isn't there we're going to see this
March pass of 10 000 of veterans a
hugely poignant moment for them but one
where they come together in a sense of
camaraderie and a show of appreciation
from members of the public very much so
and I think for any of the men and women
here who've served together there is
this shared sense of what it is like
what the job entails and it is a
difficult job and as many of the men and
women here will tell you if they've been
on active service they won't have come
home with all the colleagues they left
with and I think that shared experience
is what makes moments like this
particularly important I met someone who
served in the Falklands he's never been
to this March this is his first time on
the 40th anniversary of the Falklands he
said it felt like normally for me it's a
private moment but actually 40 years on
I think it is important to get together
to remember what we went through the
people who didn't come home with us and
to be part of this and 10 000 people is
a lot of people and the atmosphere is
that strange balance between very
respectful very reverent and one of
great remembrance but also a coming
together and an importance of that as
well that's right and I spoke to
somebody who'd served in Afghanistan and
after just six weeks broke his back so
had the most extraordinary experience
and is now
Gathering raising money for the for the
poppy appeal and and really wanting to
stay involved with his his comrades but
a really moving day for people like him
who've seen suffered themselves but also
seen others suffer so much and I think
that's why the Royal British Legion is
so keen on keeping this March going and
not just for the older Generations but I
met a girl who's part of the Scottish
soldiers so these are children who've
lost parents and actions he was 12 weeks
old when her dad died in Afghanistan and
she never met him she never knew him but
through this charity and being able to
take part in days like today so it means
an awful lot to her she's with other
children who've gone through the same
thing it's a very unique grieving she
said we have and it's important they'll
be there wearing their black and yellow
stripey scarves and I'll be looking out
for them because these are the children
and we often perhaps forget the families
who are left behind as well as seeing
all the servicemen and women themselves
here but she will be taking part in this
so a real range of the ages from the
Centurion who I met to a 16 year old as
well that's right so really important
the work that the Royal Bridget does as
you say support infections but also
their families and Laura for the moment
thanks very much indeed we'll catch up
with you in just a moment but first
let's take a look at the order of events
shall we through the course of the day
coming up in around 50 minutes time at
11 o'clock the country will pause for a
two-minute silence to remember its War
dead
now after five years of conservation
work Big Ben will officially return to
Mark at the start of the Silence by
striking 11 times
wreaths will then be laid at the
cenotaph in London by senior politicians
Faith Representatives as well as members
of the Royal Family
King Charles for the first time as mono
call a a new poppy wreath incorporating
a ribbon of his racing colors and the
design is a tribute to his late mother
and his grandfather as well George VI
a wreath will also be laid on the queen
consorts behind her for the first time
as Camilla herself watches from the
balcony of the foreign Commonwealth and
development office building
around 10 000 raw British Legion
veterans will take part in a March past
they'll be joined by an estimated 10 000
members of the public who'll line White
Hall to watch the service
so I'm joined Now by Paul Jenkins who
served in the Royal Navy from 1963 to
1975 and he served on the Royal yacht A
Britannia for more than five years
thanks so much for talking to us Paul
Jenkins this morning really appreciate
it tell us first of all about your time
on the Royal yacht Britannia what was
that experience like for you
it was a very great experience it was a
very big surprise I was asked to go on
board I stayed in a book for five years
[Applause]
I'm across members of the royal family
in your time there
oh yes permanent on Royal Duty
um when the queen finished the
all the speeches and things that came on
board and they were dressed down and
they'd walk on and speak to all the crew
on the Sunday morning a member of the
crews will go to the church service in
the Royal Apartments
and what was that like to to see her
come on board like that what did it mean
to the crew
it was a great great privilege I'd make
us proud We were proud of the queen God
bless her and also to do
and having memories like that personally
yourself
does today have an added sadness for you
as it is it the first remembrance Sunday
service since her death
very much so because
we've known it for many many years the
yacht the I'm in commission for 50 years
and a lot of the Britannia boys have
known the king as he is now on the queen
for many many years in fact we've all
grown up with him and I believe the
King's birthday is on Monday and he's
three years younger than me so I know
we'd all know him very very well
and meanwhile the Royal British Legion
plays such an important role today
doesn't it organizing that the veterans
March past later I know you've got a
long history of fundraising for them
getting involved in their poppy appeal
why why is it so important to you
well it's got to be remembered what's
now to me is a very great privilege
cities young Cadets now doing it the
children at school are told now about
the second world told about the first
world war they're now beginning to
revive all those but all those people
that's died in all these conflicts and I
hope the children of today will not get
any matters like us because that means
the last people go to a wall and I hope
they will never have to go to another
War
yeah and so what does it mean to you
when you see members of the public all
generations wearing the poppy
they fills you with pride it's just to
show now that people still remember all
age groups like like I said they're now
being taught about it in school as well
which is a great great comfort you know
a group previous to the children to
learn all about their ancestors and
hopefully they'll never see a war zone
ever again
two-minute silence is observed have you
thought what you might be reflecting on
in that moment
well yes I will think about people
passed on present I mean I did lose a
few friends in the Far East when we were
in the 60s and I still know the families
and we remember them all we remember all
the servicemen were done and civilians
because even the civilians have passed
away as well through conflict
for Paul Jenkins we really appreciate
you taking a moment to talk to us here
on Sky News thanks very much indeed for
your time
thank you
well our events commentator Alistair
Bruce will be keeping a very close eye
on events and talking us through them
throughout the morning Alistair a hugely
important day for members of the Armed
Forces for veterans but also for members
of the public who want to reflect on
those who've made the ultimate sacrifice
serving their country
very much so and while we concentrate on
what's happening in London we must
remember that in Edinburgh Cardiff and
Belfast and every village and every town
and every city of the United Kingdom and
then across the Commonwealth people at
their own 11 o'clock will be gathering
to mark this and it's an extraordinary
ceremonial because it's one of the few
that has such huge buy-up people are
very happy to play their part in
remembering the cost of freedom and for
those who are wearing their medals or
have their own memories and for the
families who supported them through the
time they served it is a very poignant
moment and it's often difficult to
convey this to younger Generations
except that our news programs are full
of quite harrowing experiences shown to
us of war that are taking place in
Europe again
and I think that for that reason this
moment of silence the two minutes that
people will share in different places
around the United Kingdom and focused on
the king here at the Senate half at 11
o'clock is a very special and worthy
time of reflection
as you say people
in their own way up and down the country
other services taking place in in towns
and cities across the map but give us an
idea of what we can expect from this
Remembrance Day service here at the
cenotaph
thank you
well we're seeing the bands bring
various parts of this serving Armed
Forces together in order to create the
framing of this National Act of
remembrance and after they're all in
place the Armed Forces as it were
holding the ground with the veterans
almost 10 000 of them waiting up towards
Trafalgar Square to take their own March
past we then see representatives of the
many commonwealth countries and of the
dependencies and of the government and
of the opposition parties come and take
their place and finally
just before 11 o'clock the king will
lead members of the royal family out and
they will stand in silence while the gun
is fired on horse guards parade to start
the two-minute silence and in that
two-minute silence people are invited to
bring their own thoughts and place them
in the cenotaph which means empty tomb
which was built to stand 102 years ago
in order to provide exactly that a place
for people to put their thoughts and
their reflections
and how
difficult today how pointing today do
you think this will be for King Charles
the first time that he will lay a wreath
as Monarch and the first time since of
course his mother the queen passed away
the king like his mother the queen is a
servant and as a servant Sovereign is
there to represent the nation and when
he lays the wreath whatever private
thoughts he has he carries on the ACT
that his great-grandfather King George V
began after the first world war and it's
been carried on by sovereigns ever since
and in that act of service to the nation
he represents all those who wish to be
present there at the cenotaph OR at
their own various events around the
country in Commonwealth or watching with
us and so it is that moment of course
poignant because his mum isn't around
and actually it was this time last year
we were told the queen was not going to
be able to attend which is a reminder
that throughout her life she always saw
this as one of those events she had to
try and attend no matter what and the
King will be the same
well Alyssa I know that we'll be
rejoining you shortly and you'll be
commentating throughout the morning on
the events here at the cenotar but for
the moment thanks very much indeed
and just to let you know that a little
bit earlier our security and defense
editor Deborah Haynes spoke to the chief
of the defense staff Admiral Sir Tony
radakin they discussed the war in
Ukraine as well as pressures on defense
spending but she began by asking about
remembrance
I think remembrance Sunday is always
poignant I think it's poignant for the
whole nation this special moment when we
pause to reflect on the sacrifice and
commitment of others to provide our
freedom today
I think there's a special poignancy this
year with both the loss of her majesty
another loss of a second world war
veteran and I also think it's poignant
when we have once again the Specter of
war in Europe
and all that that entails and a country
that's been invaded and is fighting for
its freedom we're remembering the um
those who gave their lives in the first
and the second world wars and like he
said right now Europe has War once again
on its soil How likely is it that this
could actually escalate into the Third
World War
I think what you've seen we're
approaching now nearly nine months
is that the war is relatively contained
in terms of geography
the impact of the war is enormous that's
Global the impact on food prices the
impact on millions of people and whether
or not they were going to get the grain
that Ukraine provides the impact on all
of us whether it's inflation or the
energy crisis and I think those are all
a reminder that even though the war
itself might be relatively physically
contained what it means is millions of
people that have been displaced from
their country millions of people that
are being attacked and they're losing
their energy or their water doesn't work
anymore millions of people fighting for
their freedom
that's what you're seeing and tens of
thousands of people that are dying or
are injured and and it's that reminder
that these precious values of of freedom
of democracy of that your territory is
your own and that when that's attacked
then the right people defend those and
they fight to get them back
and we're talking
um just after Russia has given this
order to withdraw its troops from
Hearthstone City in the south of Ukraine
how significant is that
I think it's significant in the sense
that once again you're seeing Russia
fail Russia's failed on all of its
strategic objectives it wanted to
subjugate Ukraine the opposite is hap
has happened Ukraine is fighting for its
freedom it wanted to take control of the
Cities you saw that fail it wanted to to
weaken NATO NATO is stronger and now
you're seeing a war that inevitably at
the Tactical level has twists and turns
but you're seeing a Russia under
pressure
taking Desperate Measures that's why
he's had to mobilize additional people
but it's it's got to try and overcome
a nation that's fighting for its freedom
a nation that we're supporting alongside
lots of other International countries
whether that's cash whether that's
Armament whether that's ammunition
for your U.S counterpart
um General Mark milley has said that the
withdrawal um in her son could provide a
window of opportunity for negotiations
between the two sides what do you think
I think that those windows will be
determined by
president zielinski and President Putin
and undoubtedly the Tactical events
might open those windows a little bit
more
but we've got to respect that Ukraine is
fighting for its territory its future
its survival
and this is a success for Ukraine but at
the same time Ukraine continues to be
attacked Ukraine has lost ground that it
needs to win back Ukraine has got
millions of people that are not living
in their homes they're either living
elsewhere in Ukraine or in the rest of
Europe they've got millions of people
that are suffering from the impacts of
the electrical infrastructure having
been attacked or the water
infrastructure being attacked it is a
war crime to to a to to deliberately
attack civilians and and that's what's
still going on is there any change in
your assessment on the likelihood of
Russia backed into a corner resorting to
a nuclear strike in Ukraine I think
we've got to be really careful of of of
Reckless rhetoric where
where the these noises are made about
about nuclear whether it's a dirty bomb
or it's a tactical nuclear weapon we
should be really careful about that
language that would be another
total
horrific step and we don't see that that
we're on a pathway to to that to that
particular Specter and we've also got to
be really clear that if we started to go
down that path that it would lead to
incredibly serious consequences but
where none of us are on that path and
Russia I think has tried to to reassure
in that sense and I think we've been
really clear as to how dangerous that
that particular route would be
um Sky News reported this week about
about
claims that Russia has transported
captured British and law anti-tank
missiles
U.S anti-tank javelins and U.S Stinger
anti-aircraft missiles to Iran along
with loads of cash 122 million pounds
worth in cash in exchange for dozens of
drones these deadly Shah head drones
that they've been using that Russia's
been using in Ukraine were you aware of
this so I went I won't go into the
detail of intelligence reports but we've
always been aware that when we provide
some of our weaponry and it's going into
a war zone there's a risk that that
Weaponry might be captured and and so
what I can offer you is that the the
technology that we're talking about is
technology of 20 30 years ago and then
that technology is used in the
manufacturing process to provide the
weapons of today and and so I we're
conscious that when we provide Armament
and support to a Ukraine that's in in a
war then there might be some of those
weapons that end up being captured and
that's taken into account when when
we'll go through our assessment as to
what's going to be provided so are you
going to do anything about it if Iran is
trying to develop end-laws
so we're in a constant competition with
certain Nations it's very much the case
with Iran but it's
it's a it's a fact that when you provide
your weapons to to Country X
in the middle of a war they may not
necessarily stay in country X the
chancellor is going to be giving his
Autumn statement on Thursday how
confident are you that defense will be
protected from the impact of inflation
and foreign exchange
I can't go into the detail of of a
financial statement statement that's
that's that's going to be announced
later this week but what I can
offer you is the seriousness with which
the situation is being discussed we have
a prime minister he's been prime
minister for just over two weeks he's
had numerous conversations with the
defense secretary with me about the
security situation in Europe but also
the globe but we specifically had an
hour with the Prime Minister and the
chancellor and I accompanied the defense
secretary
to talk about
what would be the impact of a financial
settlement and and to the the richness
and the seriousness of that conversation
recognizing that this war in Europe is
part of the reason why we have the level
of inflation that we have and why we
have the economic pressure and therefore
in trying to deal with the economic
pressure
we need to acknowledge that at its core
is this security pressure in Europe and
and the government is is having the
right level of conversation to try and
manage that but also manage the security
situation into the future so that's why
you're seeing a conversation about
coming back to the integrated review of
last year and and and taking time to to
assess that again what what what what is
working what do we want to affirm and
what might we want to adjust and and
recognize because of the increased
aggression of Russia we we need to
adjust some of the risks that we were
taking and that might mean in the longer
term more investment but let's have that
com that that longer term conversation
as well the government keeps saying
there needed to be economic stability in
order to have things like defense
spending do you think they're now
realizing that there cannot be economic
stability without security and in terms
of having security you need therefore to
invest fully in defense
absolutely and I think you saw that with
last year's integrated review an
integrated review that tried to take
integration review that's not going to
be going to be funded unless this
gives you
according to the defense secretary
himself over the next two years are you
going to get this 8 billion pounds so I
can't I can't I can't go into the
specifics but what happens if you don't
get it so again I I think it will be
wrong to to start talking about if we
don't get it then it means this this and
this those conversations are being had
with the Prime Minister and the
chancellor their private conversations I
can assure you that those conversations
are being had they're the right
conversations and they're being blended
with what was said in last year's
integrated review what needs to be
shaped for the longer term future but
also to recognize the the immediate
economic pressure of the country is
under but also recognized as a war in
Europe and that that the the seriousness
of those conversations are being had and
that's the Assurance I can give you I'm
sure they're serious but if they don't
end up with with 8 billion pounds for
defense over the next two years then
they're meaningless it means defense has
to shrink would you resign if that
happens so so we've got to wait and see
what the Autumn statement says I think
we've got to be really cautious of of of
of of the risk of being a bit too shrill
and saying right if if this happens then
I'm going to you know yeah this person
is going to resign and that I I'm much
more in their space of the right
conversations are being had let's wait
and see what the Autumn statement says
let's take stop then let's recognize
there's a blend going on of economic
pressures that have to be serviced and
security pressures that have to be
serviced and the right conversations are
being had to allow to allow those
solutions to emerge
chief of the defense staff for Admiral
Sir Tony radican talking there to our
security and defense editor Deborah
Haynes and so you join us here live at
the cenotaph in London as members of the
Armed Forces veterans senior politicians
and ambassadors and Faith leaders as
well of course as thousands of members
of the public are gathering to pay
tribute to those who've lost their lives
in past conflicts
there's a two-minute silence at 11
o'clock of course and as we head up to
that let's just bring in our Royal
correspondent here with me Laura bundog
and it is an extraordinary scene here
isn't it Laura and so many members of
the public here lining these streets I
don't know is that 15 deep or so and a
kind of low level hum of chat chatter
there's a kind of A really lovely
atmosphere it's kind of respectful isn't
it yes it's hard isn't it to place the
atmosphere here but I think it is a warm
respect for the Armed Forces many in the
crowd obviously wearing medals
themselves appreciating perhaps without
doubt the efforts the um the work that
the military does and wanting to be here
in person to see that and of course
there is another big moment today this
is as king Charles's first opportunity
to lay the wreath as Monarch as
Sovereign he stands on behalf of the
queen since 2017
um as we will remember she would stand
at the balcony and watch down many saw
that as the first step really and that
shift towards handing over some of the
duties and responsibilities perhaps so
we would be prepared for this very day
this very moment but an incredibly
significant moment for him I mean he
knows the routine he obviously knows
what to do where to stand how it all
works because it is a very very ordered
series of events here but I think that
two-minute silence and we saw it often
didn't we following the death of the
queen those moments of pause you could
almost see on his face the significance
at the moment and I wouldn't be
surprised if we see as Monarch Charles
looking reflexive remembering obviously
not just the service Personnel but the
queen too when we know this was such an
important event for her she missed it so
few times it was last year when at the
very very last minute she wasn't able to
come and she sprained her back but I
think there was genuine concern at that
point as well but far a couple of
pregnancies an overseas tour she was
here every single year it was 50 years
ago since Charles laid his first Reef
here so like I say he's an old hand when
it comes to this but nonetheless I think
being here being there at the cenotive
with that wreath for the nation is an
incredibly big moment for him well
that's right and and for the royal
family as they reflect no no doubt not
just on the deaths of those who've lost
their lives fighting in conflicts but
also of the queen herself and remind us
who's going to be here from the royal
family so we will see a succession of
reads being laid obviously the king will
lay his first we'll see William as
Prince of Wales now lay a wreath the
reads are interesting actually that the
Kings wreath very much based on the
design of his mothers and his
grandfathers will carry the Royal racing
colors of scarlet purple and gold a
slightly different design we're told so
not quite as many poppies but larger
poppies but very much a nod and a a
tribute to the queen in his wreath Queen
consort has a reason it'll be laid not
by her but by an equity that will be
laid to and then the Prince of Wales on
behalf of him and and his wife Princess
of Wales would be laying that and we're
seeing this transition of power aren't
we so there's William stepping up into
the role his father had for so many
years here uh in the same way his father
has and I think that's played out too
when you look at the prime ministers who
are here too they it won't be every
single former prime minister laying a
wreath but certainly when you see how
many prime ministers there are most of
whom are of course Rishi sunak you the
queen and would have met the queen you
see this this transition apart there's a
very traditional moment isn't it it's
interesting how it sort of reflects so
much of our Lives indeed it well Laura
thanks very much indeed and and of
course after the laying of the Reeds we
will have at 11 o'clock the country
pausing for a two-minute silence to
remember its War dead and after five
years of conservation work Big Ben will
officially return to Mark the start of
the silence by striking 11 times and we
will see Reed then laid at the cenotaph
by the members of the royal families who
were saying senior politicians those
Faith Representatives as well
so huge amount on show here in Whitehall
our events commentator Alistair Bruce
will take us through every step of the
way Alistair
thank you
well we'll be joined by Aleister very
shortly he's uh be joining us in just
one second but as our role correspondent
just there Laura bondoc was saying we
will see King Charles for the first time
as Monarch laying this new poppy wreath
which incorporates a ribbon of his
racing colors and the design is a
tribute to his late mother as well as
his grandfather George VI
and are wreath will also be laid on the
queen consort's behalf for the first
time as Camilla watches from the balcony
of the foreign Commonwealth and
development office building No Doubt
with other members of the royal family
also looking down on proceedings
and then we will get the march of the
veterans around 10 000 Royal British
Legion veterans will take part in the
March past
and in the meantime an estimated 10 000
members of the public who are aligning
these streets of Whitehall to watch the
service as well of course
[Music]
alongside the new reads
they will be accompanied by handwritten
cards bearing
their Majesty's new ciphers the king and
the Queen consorts
into Wales will lay the wreath
previously laid by his father featuring
The Prince of wales's feathers
and it'll also bear a new ribbon in
Welsh red
[Music]
and as we were just hearing from Laura
the service will also be attended by the
Princess of Wales the Earl and Countess
of Wessex the Princess Royal and vice
admiral sir Tim Lawrence
also the Duke and Duchess of Gloucester
the Duke of Kent and Princess Alexandra
[Music]
and while our focus is currently here on
the cenotaph in Whitehall here in London
there will be Services going on up and
down the country
and silences held
in villages towns and cities across the
United Kingdom as people take a moment
to pay tribute
to those service men and women who have
lost their lives
[Music]
our events commentator Alistair Bruce
wherever you are around the United
Kingdom or further afield we are
gathering our thoughts here in
Westminster
as the music is played trade with all
the usual
Traditions that have been followed since
the beginning of this ceremony so many
years ago
heart of Oak which was composed by Dr
Boyce reminds us very much of the Royal
Navy's involvement in the protection of
this island followed by the minstrel boy
and man of harlech which we hear now
the music will give way to the sky boat
song and carry us in our thoughts to
Scotland
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
s the fourth Battalion the Highlanders
the Royal Regiment of Scotland
and with the mass bands of the household
division
and
musicians from the Royal Navy and the
Royal Air Force
this act of remembrance will follow
at the center the cenotaph built
in
1920 to
be a focus
for the countless lives lost
during the first World War
designed with the empty tomb at the top
the intention that every family that
passed by could place into that
chilled whom the warm memories of the
person that they had lost
foreign
[Music]
foreign
this year is the 40th anniversary of the
Falklands War
255 people were lost
recovering the islands from the attack
by Argentina in 1982.
for many of that generation the chance
to come here to the senator for reflect
upon those lives lost
amongst the countless of the first world
war who
represent a generation long gone
but also the second world war there is
one of the
veterans today at 101 will be marching
past
amongst all these memories of
more recent veterans who wait
for the two-minute silence that will
start at exactly 11 o'clock
[Music]
foreign
the Glorious dead inscribed into this
Portland Stone Memorial
it was first erected in 1919 made out of
wood lath and plaster
the king attended the service it was
intended only to be used for one
occasion but the
national response to the memorial meant
that it was
built permanently in stone
[Music]
and it has represented not just the
first world war but all
conflicts sense the loss of those in the
armed services but also in the civil
services
the civilian services like the police
the ambulance
fire brigade who
looked after London in the Blitz and who
have dealt with bombs and terrorist
actions
or who have done what they can in
service to keep the Nations safe as the
Pipers play flowers of the forest
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
wherever you are you will have your own
thoughts about war you may have
people you are remembering now
you may be so young that war seems very
distant concept and yet now in Europe
there is war
and for those who have a memory
you will be bearing that through this
ceremony
for me I remember particularly
Guardsman Jim Reynolds who looked after
me
and was part of my old platoon
in 1982
he was 19.
when he was killed he had already
taken out a machine gun post on Mount
tumble done
and then
he went to the aid of a wounded comrade
and in the process
he was killed
a selfless act that was among so many
remembered by all of us
here today
[Music]
the music Nimrod was written by Elgar to
remember a great friend of his
while it plays
I suggest you think about whoever it is
or whatever thoughts you want to muster
for the two-minute silence later on
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
s gather with their reads and so many
stories in their minds as their
welcomed by people who have been
waiting here since quite early this
morning
[Music]
the grind being kept by the Royal Navy
the Royal Air Force and the army with
the civilian forces
and with a god of Honor from the king's
Scouts
the religious procession begins with the
processional cross that was given to the
queen
to Mark her Platinum Jubilee
made with Oak from the Sandringham
estate and decorated
with a Welsh daffodil and Irish Shamrock
English Rose and Scottish thistle
there are 17 silver studs one for each
year of the Queen's reign
marked today with the poppies and
carried by Arya nagpur who is the cross
Bearer followed by
Jonathan Simpson the sergeant of the
best stream
and also the children and Gentlemen of
the Chapel's Royal
ten children who all attend the city of
London school and six gentlemen in
ordinary to lead the services
and among the clergy
the chaplain General the Reverend
Michael Parker
the 10 Colonel the Reverend Cannon Paul
Wright sub Gene of the Chapel's Royal
and also
the dean of his Majesty's Chapel's Royal
James Sarah malali who is also the Lord
Bishop of London
[Applause]
after that two-minute silence the royal
family and political leaders and
representatives of the Commonwealth will
leave the Senate off
and it'll be handed over to the Royal
British Legion who
the poppy appeal
to allow the veterans to March past and
pay their respects
now the great Memorial that shares
with the cenotaph
Whitehall to the women of World War II
of whom our late Queen was but one and a
very significant
member of the
Army territorial service
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
rests in the hands of a younger
generation trained daily for the
protection of the United Kingdom like so
many of those veterans who reflect upon
previous generations
[Music]
prime minister and the leader of the
opposition
other cabinet ministers and
representatives of the other parties who
will lay their reads
also here today
former prime ministers
who will witness
the reflection the nation makes
upon any prime minister at any time
sets the responsibility for leading the
nation and making decisions in time of
conflict
foreign
ER Prime Ministers gathered to witness a
serving prime minister lay his wreath
after the Royal Family
thank you
the chiefs of the armed services led by
the chief of Defense staff firstly Lord
chief of the general staff and the chief
of the air staff with three
representatives of the civilian services
and then from Nepal and Ireland and from
[Music]
all the commonwealth countries
Representatives who will be laying their
wreaths around the cemetov but upon the
chief of Defense staff and the other
Chiefs the responsibility of maintaining
the United Kingdom's defense
at all times
and remembering the cost of War
[Music]
the parade is brought to attention which
is to prepare for the arrival of his
majesty the king who will lead out the
Royal Family
as the Commonwealth Representatives
take their positions around the senatov
and make the setting complete
Representatives also from many Faith
groups across the United Kingdom who
come to attend
and represent
the many religions
and so the scene is set for the arrival
of his majesty the king
welcome to Whitehall where the king
leading the Royal Family
in front of the political leaders and
Commonwealth Representatives prepares to
lead the nation in the annual Act of
remembrance at the senatov
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
on behalf of the nation
his majesty the King has laid his wreath
and will salute the Senate off
Captain Edward Anderson lays a wreath on
behalf of her majesty the queen consort
the Prince of Wales receives his wreath
with the
feathers of the Arab parent
Israel harness the Earl of Wessex and
fortha
dressed in the uniform of the royal
Wessex human Arena a reserve unit
reminding us of so many people who serve
the Armed Forces
in the reserves
Commander Anne Sullivan presents the
Princess Royal with harith and
for her so many visits to
units of which she holds close
Association
she's an admiral in the Navy a general
in the Army and an ad Chief Marshal
in the Royal Air Force
and on behalf of the Duke of Kent
whose father was killed during the
second world war in an air crash Captain
Charles longstaff
lays the last of the royal reeds
when he returns to his position
the parade will be stood at ease
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
to the funeral March number one in B
flat minor by Beethoven watched by the
queen concert
the Prime Minister will lay his wreath
on behalf of his Majesty's government
[Music]
foreign
ER
meet with the labor party and leader of
his Majesty's opposition
[Music]
the leader of the Westminster Scottish
national party
and on behalf of the Scottish national
party applied kumaru parliamentary group
the right honorable Ian Blackford
[Music]
the right honorable sir Ed Davey leader
of the liberal Democrats
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
third leader of the Democratic unionist
Party
and leader of the Democratic unionist
Party in the House of Commons
the right honorable sir Jeffrey
Donaldson
[Music]
and representing all members of the
House of Commons and House of Lords
the Speaker of the House Commons the
white honorable sir Lindsay Hoyle
and the Lord speaker
the right honorable the Lord might fall
[Music]
thank you
and the right honorable James cleverly
Secretary of State for foreign
Commonwealth Affairs and the right
wonderful Braverman Secretary of State
for the home department on behalf of the
intelligence agencies
[Music]
the first group to lay their reads will
be the crime dependencies and overseas
territories
the bailiwick of Guernsey
baileywick of Jersey the Isle of Man
Anguilla Bermuda the British Virgin
Islands Cayman Islands the Falkland
Islands especially in our mind is 40th
anniversary of the war there Gibraltar
Montserrat Saint Helena Ascension and
Tristan de Cuna and Turks and Caicos I
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
and in groups representing a
commonwealth that laid so much of its
own blood at the battlefields in the
seas and in the skies of two world wars
and since Canada Australia
New Zealand South Africa
India
Pakistan Sri Lanka
Ghana and Malaysia
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
Nigeria Cyprus Sierra Leone Tanzania
Jamaica Trinidad and Tobago
Uganda and Kenya
although not a member of the
Commonwealth and therefore not
represented here we remember that so
many
in Zimbabwe also laid down their lives
[Music]
foreign
will be laid raised by Malawi
Malta which was given a George cross and
still bears that decoration on its flag
Zambia
The Gambia Singapore
Guyana Botswana
lesoto and Barbados
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
formerly known as Swaziland Tonga Fiji
Bangladesh the Bahamas
Grenada
Papua New Guinea
Seychelles
Commonwealth of Dominica
Saint Lucia Saint Vincent and the
Grenadines
[Music]
foreign
s represent the breadth of
reach that the wars had
and a reminder
of the danger of World War
[Music]
the final group from the Commonwealth
Belize Antigua and Barbuda the Maldives
said Christopher and Nevis
[Music]
Brunei Jerusalem
Namibia Cameroon Mozambique
Rolanda Gabon and Togo
[Music]
the United Kingdom's closest neighbor
not in the Commonwealth is represented
now by the ambassador of Ireland to the
United Kingdom
and also with the close link
to Nepal
the ambassador of Nepal
[Music]
foreign
it is the Armed Forces who principally
fight the battles and who are constantly
ready to defend the United Kingdom on
their behalf led by the chief of Defense
staff
also will lay there is for the Royal
Navy
the Pharisee Lord and chief of Naval
staff for the Army the chief of the
general staff and for the Royal Air
Force the chief of the estof
foreign
[Music]
by those in the armed forces
to remember the civilian civilian
Services The Merchant Navy and fishing
fleets are represented also the Air
transport auxiliary Association
and for other civilian services this
year the National Police Chiefs Council
chair
and we now prepare for
the service of remembrance which will be
led
by the dean of the Chapel's Royal to the
king
the Lord Bishop of London
[Music]
do honor to the memory of those who have
died in the service of their country and
of the crown may be so inspired by the
spirit of their love and fortitude for
forgetting all selfish and unworthy
motives we may live only to thy glory
and to the service of Mankind through
Jesus Christ Our Lord
amen
[Music]
foreign
foreign
my eyes
teach us good Lord to serve thee as thou
deservist
to give and not to count the cost
to fight and not to heed the wounds to
toil and not to seek full rest to labor
and not to ask for any reward say that
of knowing that we do thy will through
Jesus Christ Our Lord
amen
Our Father
which art in heaven Hallowed be thy name
thy kingdom come thy will be done in
earth as it is in heaven
give us this day our daily bread and
forgive us our trespasses
as we forgive them that trespass against
us and lead us not into temptation but
Deliver Us from Evil for thine is the
kingdom the power and the glory forever
and ever amen
unto God's gracious mercy and protection
we commit you the Lord bless you and
keep you the Lord make his face to shine
upon you and be gracious unto you
the Lord lived up the light of his
countenance upon you and give you his
peace this day and always
amen
the rose will be sanded followed by the
national anthem and God Save the King
shut up
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
with the salute the king will take leave
of the cenototh
having stood exactly working George V
did in 1919
Edward VII George VI and his mother
Queen Elizabeth II
he leads to royal family back into the
foreign and Commonwealth building
the national
Act of remembrance
having now been LED
after all I saw the following
led by the sergeants of the West tree
the dean subdean
and chaplain General
and then the cross Bearer with this
cross that was made especially
to be presented to the queen in her
Platinum Jubilee year
before Plant Badges of the United
Kingdom in the four arms of the cross
the children and Gentlemen of the
Chapel's Royal
created to go with medieval kings
as
they went with their armies
to France the
Chapel's Royal played and sang
at Agincourt in 1415 as the prime
minister
and political leaders upon whom the
responsibility of how to respond
to war in Europe at this time
in the coming weeks and months
former Prime Ministers who carried that
burden
members of the cabinet
the Union flag the white Anson and the
blue Anson with the sound of the
seagulls
all that can be heard here in Whitehall
the off-white Portland Stone of the
senatov now
marked by the blood red poppies of so
many memories
when you go home
tell them of us and say
for your tomorrow
we gave R today
Admiral Sir Tony radican who spoke
earlier to us on Sky News
about the challenges faced by the Armed
Forces always being ready to
both defend the nation and also
to train the ukrainians at the moment
for the challenge they face and the
representatives of the civilian services
the Ukrainian flag flying high above
Whitehall
as the clouds of War are not so far away
from London
and in the balconies where members of
the royal family watched this ceremony
they've now withdrawn the
Earl of wessexymphofa will represent the
king later in horse guards parade and
take the salute
of all those
who are gathered as veterans today as
the
Major General commanding household
division
General Chris geeker has just left the
parade and they stand at ease
[Music]
and the tempo will slightly change as
the young service people get the chance
to relax in the stand easy position lest
we forget the freedoms they died for
the parade will now reconfigure in order
for the veterans to have their moment
got to London some of them over the last
few days
and they have been forming up in their
regimental units and organizations as
the representatives of the royal British
Legion move forward in order to lay
their reeds
amongst them representing transport for
London Mr Gary best representing Legion
Scotland Lieutenant Commander Martin
Hawthorne
Royal convert X Services league candle
Michael Warnick
the Royal Air Force Association Vice
Marshall Nigel barrister
and the Army benevolent fund soldiers
charity by General Sir James everard and
the Royal Naval Association by Mr
Stanley Keith Ridley the first wreath
was laid by the national president who
recovers his Bella hat he is
Lieutenant General James battle
foreign
Naval Association
and it's been incredible to see the
volunteers that have stepped forward to
support the Royal British Legion gen
related
different parts of the United Kingdom
this year
and also poppy Scotland in Scotland also
everywhere a chance to make
contributions towards the national poppy
appeal
all Charities are having to find
better ways to draw cash when few people
carry it and
increasingly the tap screen
opportunities will be used
Dennis James abroad on behalf of army
benevolent fund
meanwhile the bands of the high
subdivision will be dividing and moving
to position to bring the different
Columns of those
who will be marching past shortly
agreed by the king being played
and we'll just enjoy as they play
foreign
[Music]
Legion are being laid individually
we can prepare for
very nearly 10 000 people from around
300 different armed forces and civilian
associations who will March past the
cenotype
but of course throughout the United
Kingdom other events have been taking
place and we see
that on behalf of Scotland
Legion Scotland's Lieutenant Commander
Martin Hawthorne lays his wreath with
the Saint Andrews cross picked out in
white and blue
foreign
ly for transport for London
who do so much to help people get to
this National event
it's the Stanley Keith Ridley lays his
wreath on behalf of bus drivers and
underground
Personnel who have particularly during
the second world war and the first
endured so much many of the London bus
drivers who were reservists took their
buses to France to help move the troops
around in the early parts
of the first World War
led by Sir James battle they will now
move through the Horan and Commonwealth
building and join the island of
Wessex and forth for the March pass to
arrive and give their salute in horse
guards
and the band will come to a conclusion
at the end of this tune
and over to the pipes and drums
the Royal Regiment of Scotland and
organized the March fast
[Music]
foreign
gods and the Cold Stream Gods marching
forwards first
[Music]
foreign
and
Commonwealth office building I think one
of the most moving of the reeds
brought by the widows Association a
simple white cross
of chrysanthemums which will be placed
on the south side
of the cenotaph
to remember that the family is Left
Behind and the challenges for their
families
we remember them as the pipes
play the people of Donald do
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
as the pipes transport us to the
northern part of the United Kingdom to
Scotland
from where so many went to battle
this scene is now set for the second
part of the remembrance ceremonies here
Laura bundup joins me she I watched the
moment when the king and the royal
family laid their wreaths and led the
nation
very moving day for the king
moment isn't it it is another
significant Milestone as we transition
to a new monarch and perhaps certainly
here for me today it felt like another
one of those moments where we stop we
pause and we realize that things are
different that things have now changed
and of course a huge moment for the king
his first moment as Sovereign laying the
wreath on behalf of the nation now he of
course knows this routine he laid his
first wreath here back 50 years ago and
it was in 2017 when the queen
symbolically perhaps passed that duty to
her son and we've seen him leading the
morning here at the cenotar but a very
different moment for him as Sovereign
now responsible for that and I think
particularly perhaps during the national
anthem you got a sense and you could see
that it wasn't lost on him the enormity
of this moment but a very solemn
ceremony here as expected and now of
course the March begins and there is a
clap from the crowds it's a warm respect
as how I probably describe the
atmosphere here as the march of some 10
000 service men and women will now begin
[Music]
foreign
the first column
to pass by is the Army column
led by the 16th fifth Royal Queen's
Royal Lancers the 1721st Lancers the
Royal lancers and I see all the way
along the side of them The Barking
instructions of the Garrison sergeant
major Mr Stokes and as they pass if they
have their reads you'll see they're
taken by wreath collectors
and they are supported here by some King
Scouts
King's guides do so much for this event
their volunteers at the top of their
skating time and they hand out the order
of service they form the god of Honor
either side of the
door for the royal family when they come
here and they help the reef layers with
the distribution of all this respect and
affection for the memory of past
comrades
all right
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
each of these regimental organizations
will have come together
and will doubtless after they've given
their salute to the
Earl of Wessex and fortha in horse
guards where they started their day
they'll all disperse to different places
around London the welcome is always
enormous for them you're seeing the
wonderful Cherry trousers there of the
king's Royal hazards
and it is indeed a Long Way to Tipperary
but these
wonderful veterans will go whatever
distance it is to remember the past to
come together as friends again and
to go and party later on
watched by the serving soldier of
sailors air men and women
of today these veterans some of them
injured perhaps in battle often many of
them injured in ways we can't see their
mental health affected by battle or
whatever event they attended yet even
addressing the challenges of terrorism
within the United Kingdom
but whatever it is
they're here with their memories and the
crowd on the side along with the young
service men and women wish them
extremely well under these autumnal
leaves
foreign
[Music]
it was the first time that the queen
consort laid a wreath and it's also very
special to see that the Duke of Kent
Street is still being laid difficult for
him now to do it himself
[Music]
that's right I think the Reeds
themselves
tell us a lot very symbolic obviously
the king now has a new reef it's a
different design but very much paying
tribute to the queen reflecting back on
her reads over the years and his wreath
as we saw there
large poppy set above black leaves
with the ribbons of his racing colors
the racing colors of the queen
for so many years on the Reeds she laid
here at the senator and then of course
the queen consort Camilla with her
wreath now bearing her new Cipher with
the racing colors of her grandfather
laid by neckery on her behalf
and we saw of course Prince William the
Prince of Wales now stepping into his
father's shoes as Prince of Wales laying
his wreath on behalf of himself and the
Princess of Wales too
to the Reeds themselves say in all four
Lots and I think speak to the continuity
here as well this sense of tradition but
of things marching and moving on as well
and this transition I think of power
that we've seen not just from The
Sovereign but looking at the prime
ministers who were gathered there today
as well but there is very much on
display now as the marching continues
and a lovely clap here at the cenotar as
they pass by from those you've gathered
in the crowd some 10 15 people deep
these crowds they've waited a long time
and clapping as the veterans the serving
men and women walk past and walk past
the cenotaph here
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
turning their head in salute to a
glorious dead
represented by the senator
[Music]
the first world war song O O what a
lovely War as the Royal military police
with their famous red berries passed by
foreign
the Chelsea pensioners in pensioners as
their name
they go to live at the Royal Hospital
Chelsea that was built by King Charles
II on the banks of the Thames in Chelsea
and they're these men and women hand
over their pension books and therefore
are looked after
within the system as in pensioners and
they are being organized by their
their own regimental sergeant major
and so many of these songs were sung by
soldiers in the first world war marching
to or Back From The Trenches
it's the Applause that means so much to
these veterans who served
[Music]
the former women's Royal Army Corps
passing by there now
the Armed Forces
have women in every regiment and core
and
signs of a changing Army chain been
changing Armed Forces as we look to the
Future
foreign
[Music]
for those who are less able also taken
extremely seriously
and they will
have been so well looked after by
everyone who's organized this parade
as they along with
foreign
[Music]
the wreath on behalf of the Chelsea
pensioners prepared to
hand it over to the wreath gatherers
foreign
[Music]
by the time this parade has passed by
just sort of 10 000 veterans will have
given their salute in reflection of
their own memories
our families will be proudly watching
them do it
encouraging them on as they March
through their lives carrying the
memories of conflicts sometimes the
scars too
and always helped by other veterans
around them to deal with the challenges
that Warfare have created and to always
feel part of something
the United Kingdom with its military
covenants which have been signed up to
by towns and cities
and organizations in government to make
sure that those who have served
are always looked after but this is
their day remembrance Sunday the chance
for them as this has happened at times
Villages cities all over the United
Kingdom
that Unity that is shared and that
brings both sadness but joy
most definitely too
[Music]
I'm wearing the Royal Air Force tartan
from the
women's Royal Air Force
they will lay their wreath too
as we heard these strains of there'll
always be in England
[Music]
we said at the beginning of this
Act of remembrance how especially this
year we marked the 40th anniversary of
the Falklands War
when
the task force or Navy Army Air Force
were gathered
in very short time
to travel 8 000 miles to recover Islands
[Music]
just beyond the shores of South America
and ensure that British subjects there
could continue to choose their form of
government and Future
for those veterans and a special Mark
has come this year from all those who
are gathered as the Royal Air Force
start to pass by and we see the
tarmac here gradually become redder and
redder
his majesty the king lead the nation
here at the cenotaph for the first time
in his Reign carrying on a tradition
that was so carefully followed by his
late mother Queen Elizabeth II
we have watched the royal family gather
with
political leaders and Commonwealth
Representatives
most of all
we've had you
with your memory of what it means to
reflect upon War
and to desire that it never happened
again
as Europe is challenged by War again
let us remember the Dead
and let us make sure
that we reflect remembrance With Honor
this year
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]